where are you at there is no schedule
before the stream so you will have to
connect in some way if you are wanting
to know when I stream next and I'm
actually wanting to do more live
streaming on chest comm some more mix it
up okay
be one Queen d2 the pond pushes may be
available okay
Knight to g3 it's always a little bit
awkward to get this king side working
well with the pond on f3
I don't have that anymore okay I'm gonna
have to take two steps with my knight I
don't know if I really wanted to play my
Bishop out here because of maybe a pawn
push okay my knight is pinned huh I
guess b5 is coming maybe this is okay
after all b5 I'm assuming is going to
happen okay this F file opening up is
that really gonna be a problem how could
I back up and if you take then I could
play on the a file let's try that just
want to get developed
what okay I could just take that the
Queen's there to defend laterally I'm
not afraid of that this is this has to
be better for me this position has to be
better okay my knight could do something
else get to this square okay to capture
towards the side let's have a good
reason not to get to the a file that
rook has not needed on the B file
anymore I could trade some more and can
I kick this Queen away no she's gonna go
here what about rook a to Brooke a 1 and
then this
becomes a problem that might be a
slip-up might the computer have just
slipped up right there it does
definitely slips up it's hit three times
pawn push pawn to a4 but what what what
if I play a four rook a four and then b4
hmm Knight here with then this pawn push
ah that might be working right here if
Queen here gets trapped Knight c3 Queen
a six pawn push let's try that
I see three pawn push now
am I just winning this actually let me
go back
maybe there's something better I could
always do repetition I could get a draw
here if I want the computer sees nothing
better they're not valuing the computer
isn't valuing its position and as any
better than mine because of this Center
I have a space advantage
rook a 4 and B 4 I feel after rook a4
I'm gonna have something something's
gonna happen against that rook a3 and
then c4 maybe rook a3 and then c4 I'm
gonna try to win I know I could draw in
this position but I'm gonna look for a
win and I'm not getting b4 in MI nope
okay let me take that clean away and now
I have a space advantage however where's
this night going okay and now I want my
attention over here all of a sudden or
maybe I don't I want to stop this pawn
advance maybe get the dark square Bishop
Soph the board and exploit these dark
square weak
says okay closing things up now I think
I take am i winning this pond nope
because of that in between well if I
take here with check the king comes here
to defend the bishop okay I have to come
back over here now pod push my knight is
unprotected here man
hmm not easy not easy
okay Knight here why haven't I been
thinking about that for a while Knight
here controls these squares I want to
get rook here ah my knight is gonna be
gone now hang on hang on how many time
takes it could take here
hmm it's gotta do something 33 seconds
not any time at all going back does this
pick off a pun I just want to get really
active here pawn push there's gonna be a
check a side step that I need a flight
square for my King immediately okay I'm
actually getting activity why didn't you
see how this beast defense stuff though
wait and you see how it defends stuff
why did I even do that
now this diagonals opened up Queen trade
this is probably losing ah I'm on the
rook can I get back there in time if
there's a Queen trade Oh
12 seconds it's not a lot of time I
think this is maybe winning unless they
do that move uh King up nine point nine
seconds would it really do that I got to
come back yep gotta break this up
I gotta go back 3.7 seconds is just it's
not happening 2.4 this might have been a
draw might have been 0.1 I'm to spend
too much time Oh tough to out blitz a
computer